(audience applauds)
- Your dad cheered you on,
but I hear you have something
that you do before events, right?
- Yes, um before I know,
go go into competitions,
I like to settle my
nerves by singing karaoke.
(laughter)
and I think it's a great
way to just ex-ahhhhh
(laughter)
to just express myself
and basically alleviate
a lot of stress from everybody else,
and I had a lot of people join in on fun,
and I actually brought a karaoke machine
to the Concigowa, in Tokyo, Japan,
because I knew I was just going to be,
you know, under a lot of stress.
And I didn't want to feel that.
And so, I brought a karaoke machine,
and one of the songs that
I actually got to sing,
that I love singing, is
songs by you. So it was
- What song?
- It's Because of You,
that's the song I would sing.
(laughter)
(cheering)
- Wait! That is like a
super depressing song!
(laughter)
that is a super depressing
song to get you amped up.
- Well it's me talking
about my past, like,
talking to my past self
and all the mistakes
that I've made,
and just, basically,
like I'm in a I know
what I've been through
and I'm gonna come back
I'm gonna come out of it,
and I'm gonna get stronger,
and I'm gonna look forward.
Why? Because of you.
And it's a great song. Come on.
- I love that!
- I've learned the hard
way that the first to cry
started with
(singing) because of you
I never strayed too far
from the sidewalk.
(cheering and laughter)